[Musique]
Valérie d'Aido, bonsoir.
Bonsoir SVW. Bon, nous vous recevons
pour une chaîne, ça va être compliqué
aujourd'hui. Nous vous recevons pour une
chaîne internet qui s'appelle Serview.
Nous sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ?
Je m'appelle Valérie d'Aido, j'ai 59 ans
et je j'ai fait beaucoup de déco, enfin
les gens je pense m'ont connu avec une
émission de déco. J'ai été journaliste
et là j'ai un spectacle et euh et j'ai
une chaîne YouTube où je bosse un peu
dessus. Voilà en gros hein.
Bon on va rentrer un peu plus dans le
détail pendant cette interview. On a
décidé de vous faire venir parce que un
jour vous vous avez évoqué notre chaîne
dans des
céit un petit compliment et c'est notre
communauté qui nous l'a fait remonter et
on s'est intéressé à vous, on s'est
intéressé à votre façon de penser, ce
que vous partagiez, les gens qui vous
suivaient et on a trouvé ça bien.
Ah bah merci.
Et non, on n pas gentil, on pas
on a trouvé ça bien. Est-ce que vous
essayez de transmettre cette envie de
s'informer ?
Vous avez un vrai caractère trempé, un
caractère en acier trempé et nous on
aime les gens comme ça.
Merci.
Et donc on est très heureux de vous
recevoir.
Euh on va parler tout un tas de choses
aujourd'hui comme un peu de certes de
rénovation, un peu un peu de spectacle,
un peu de géopolitique,
un peu de tout,
un peu de politique
pour parler vrai.
H
Valérie, comment vous jugez le monde du
showbiz ? Télé.
Bah assez compliqué parce que c'est à la
fois un milieu privilégié parce que pour
arriver à être quelqu'un de connu que ce
soit au cinéma, à la télé ou et cetera
dans les médias, c'est très dur, faut
bosser. C'est pas comme ça. Il y a des
fois des trucs qui arrivent, des gens
qui deviennent super connus parce qu'ils
sont ils ont fait une émission de
téléréalité ou parce que ils sont
retrouvés machin. Mais en règle
générale, c'est du taf. Et après, c'est
un milieu très particulier. Moi, j'ai
très peu de de vrais amis euh dans ce
milieu. Euh mes amis, c'est bah parce
que c'est des gens qui sont
assez tourn vers eux, assez tourné vers
euh vers leur carrière, vers leur image.
Et moi, je suis pas quelqu'un, enfin
moi, mon image, je m'en fous un petit
peu en fait en vrai. J'ai jamais essayé
de lisser qui j'étais ou de minimiser
les trucs que je pensais ou en me disant
"Ah, ça va nuire à ma carrière, j'ai
trop de j'ai trop de je parle trop.
Souvent, on me dit que je suis grande
gueule dans ce métier et cetera
peut-être, mais c'est un métier un
milieu très particulier. Et en même
temps euh j'ai quand même des potes qui
sont là mais euh
pas tant que ça. Avant de parler de
bâtiments et tout un tas de choses comme
ça, de rénovation énergétique, voilà,
toutes ces petites choses qui embêtent
tous les primos accédents
h
quel regard vous portez sur la
politique, sur la géopolitique, sur la
finance,
sur le monde, tu veux dire presque ?
Vas-y, fais-nous ça.
En fait, je trouve qu'en ce moment, on
est un peu dans un marasme très
particulier. C'est-à-dire que
politiquement, moi, j'arrive même plus à
savoir qui est de droite, qui est de
gauche, qui dit quoi, qui fait quoi.
J'ai l'impression les gens qui sont
actuellement au gouvernement ont une
image de la France ou aimeraiit refaire
la France un petit peu comme la France
des années, on va dire 40, la blouse à
l'école, le SNU, des espèces de trucs un
peu passéistes.
J'ai pas l'impression qu'on avance. J'ai
l'impression envie de reculer et en même
temps on massacre tout ce qui a fait je
trouve le le bien de la France à savoir
tous les services public. L'hôpital ne
s'est jamais aussi mal porté. Les profs
n'ont jamais été aussi maltraités. Euh
les chercheurs,
ah bon les chercheurs, on en parle même
pas. Les universités, tout va mal. Et tu
as l'impression que il y a un espèce de
de c'est tellement le bordel que ça
avance un scandale
efface celui d'après. Enfin, c'est un
vrai bordel. Moi, je pense beaucoup à
tous ces gens qui le matin sont obligés
de se lever pour payer leur loyer, la
bouffe, les mommes, les colles, si
possible un peu de plaisir, les crédit,
le crédit, le machin et qui se disent
"Mais [__] on va où là
parce que je trouve queon a de moins en
moins de vista sur ce qui va se passer.
C'est que là ça fait quand même un
moment qu'on nous dit qu'on est en
guerre. Oui, on est en guerre
clairement.
On sort de d'une pandémie où on a tous
été grinté.
Et je trouve que c'est très très
compliqué de se projeter dans l'avenir.
Moi, j'ai une gamine qui a 31 ans et un
fils qui a 30 ans. Ils ont pas envie
d'avoir d'enfant et je comprends en fait
parce qu'ils ont verbalisé pourquoi ?
Ouais. Ils l'ont verbalisé parce que
c'est très compliqué. Ils ont besoin de
de de
tunes
de tune clairement. Ils sont
de bah et puis surtout de prof d'école.
Et tu te dis je comprends moi euh quand
tu entends le président de la République
dire bah la France faut réarmer euh la
France démographiquement. Alors déjà moi
le mot réarmement pour parler d'enfant
j'ai envie de chialer. J'entends hein
qu'il faut plus d'enfants et qu'on en
fait pas. Mais à quel moment tu as envie
de faire des enfants dans cette société
là en ce moment ? C'est le bordel.
Bosser, c'est dur. Trouver du taf, c'est
dur. Je peux plus entendre ce discours.
Oui, on va on va fliquer les chômeurs.
Mais à quel moment tu te dis dans ta
tête "Ah non mais les chômeurs ils ont
voulu être chômeurs, ils sont super
bien." Mais non, en fait personne n'est
bien au RSA, personne n'est bien au
chômage. À quel moment fliquz les
chômeurs ? Il y a un truc qui ne va pas.
C'est-à-dire que moi, j'ai toujours
pensé que payer des impôts, moi quand
j'ai ça m'est arrivé de très bien gagner
ma vie, euh j'en avais enfin pour moi,
c'est normal.
C'est quoi bien gagner sa vie ?
Bah, c'est gagné entre 18000 et 25000 €
par mois, ce qui est énorme. Ah non,
brut. Mais c'est quand même énorme.
Aujourd'hui, c'est plus de tout ça.
Aujourd'hui, je gagne absolument pas ça.
Euh mais ça m'est arrivé de bien gagner
ma vie et pour moi euh ça n'a jamais été
un souci de payer des impôts parce que
pour moi les impôts ça sert justement
pour les services publics. Infirmières,
les pompiers.
Exactement. Les infirmières, les
hôpitaux, les écoles, les enfin tous les
services publics. Et là aujourd'hui, je
trouve que il y a un espèce de truc où
on ne taxe pas les vrais gens qui
gagnent de l'oseille. Euh la fraude
fiscale, tu tu les tu vois tous les
jours euh on t'explique que l'évasion
fiscale coûte 100 fois plus euh que euh
la fraude au chômage ou euh la fraude
sociale. Euh et on tape toujours sur les
mêmes. Je comprends que les gens soient
déprimés, soient fatigués et ne voient
pas leur avenir parce que c'est très
compliqué. Euh pourquoi avoir supprimé
l'ISF ? Pour quelle raison ? Pour faire
plaisir à qui ? Ça a enlevé beaucoup
d'argent. Pourquoi faire travailler les
gens plus longtemps ? Pourquoi taxer les
chômeurs ? Pourquoi fliquer les plus
petits ? À un moment donné, tu te dis
mais c'est pas comme ça que ça doit
fonctionner. Une vraie société doit être
équitablement gérée. C'est-à-dire ceux
qui gagnent beaucoup plus doivent payer
leur part à la hauteur de ce qui gagne.
Tu peux pas taxer un mec qui gagne le
SMIC comme tu taxes un mec qui fait
partie du CAC 40. Enfin, tu vois, c'est
et je trouve que en ce moment, il y a
une vraie volonté dans le discours
politique de dire c'est fénace de
chômeur, c'est féas de prof. Quand tu
vois qu'il y a plus de profs devant les
écoles et qu'on se demande pourquoi, ben
c'est dur en fait d'être prof. L'argent,
ils ont parfois les classes, ils sont à
38 dans les classes.
Et puis après, tu vois tous les
scandales qui arrivent. Tu vois les en
ce moment c'est tous les gamins dans les
lycées font des TikTok en montrant
l'état déplorable de leur lycée et à
côté de ça tu apprend que Valérie PCR
donne de l'argent à un lycée privé comme
Stanislas qui a 7 hectares de terrain
des piscines des trucs. Tu dis W les
gars le l'enseignement privé ne peut pas
être mieux que l'enseignement public de
la République. Pour moi, c'est pas
possible. Euh c'est il y a des choses
qui ne vont pas mais rien n'avance. Tu
as l'impression qu'on jette des trucs,
des journalistes font des papiers,
expliquent ce qui se passe, les gens se
révoltent mais derrière qu'est-ce qui se
passe ? Rien concrètement rien.
Pas de proposition politique ou
aucune proposition politique
ou pas de cap ? Il y a pas il y a rien
qui se passe. On a changé de ministre de
l'éducation nationale. On a une ministre
qui fait à la fois l'éducation
nationale, à la fois les Jeux
Olympiques. Euh euh les gars, c'est deux
chantiers énormes et euh avec euh et tu
fais oh là là des trucs des groupes de
niveau. Même les profs écoutez les profs
en fait. Moi je suis pour qu'on écoute
les gens qui sont sur le terrain. Il y a
rien de mieux en fait. Tu peux pas faire
parler de loi et faire voter des trucs
si tu n'écoutes pas les gens qui sont
dans le truc. Tous les profs le disent,
les groupes de niveau, c'est une bêtise
absolue et ça ne fera pas évoluer les
les enfants et ça n'arrangera personne.
Les profs aujourd'hui, qu'est-ce qu'il
demandent ? Moins d'élèves dans les
classes, donc plus d'ouverture de
classe, un salaire décent évidemment et
surtout qu'on les écoute. Et là,
qu'est-ce qui se passe ? On supprime des
postes, il y a pas d'augmentation de
salaire et on propose des trucs
qui sont repêchés, tu sais pas d'où,
l'uniforme, mais c'est ça qui va faire
que les profs vont avoir envie de de le
SNU. Mais non, faut arrêter en fait,
faut arrêter tout ça. Faut arrêter de
penser que l'uniforme va sauver
l'éducation nationale. C'est c'est la
France la France noir et blanc. C'est un
c'est c'est passé tout ça. Moi à
l'époque quand j'étais à l'école,
j'avais des blouses. Voilà, on mettait
des blouses pour pas se salir en fait
hein. C'était même pas pour se
ressembler tous. Euh aujourd'hui les
uniformes à quoi faire ? Qui va
subventionner ça ? Pourquoi ? Tout cet
argent perdu qui pourrait servir
justement à augmenter les profs, à
ouvrir des classes plutôt qu'à enfermer
euh et puis pareil pour l'hôpital. Moi
ça me rend dingue de voir qu'il y a des
urgences de nuit qui sont fermées. Il y
a pas longtemps Bordeaux les urgences de
nuit fermé. Euh moi j'ai des copines
infirmières qui n'en peuvent plus. On
les a applaudis pendant le Covid. C'est
super les casseroles, les machins. Mais
concrètement, à quel moment on leur a
donné de l'argent ? On les on leur a
permis de continuer à à faire leur
travail ?
C'est fou. C'est complètement fou. Euh
quand tu te poses toutes ces questions,
j'ai envie de de me taper la tête dans
le mur. Oh,
mais avant de te taper la tête dans le
mur ou après ou après,
comment tu fais pour aller chercher les
réponses ? Comment tu fais pour
t'informer ? Comment tu fais pour aller
trianguler ton information ?
Moi, j'essaie que on en parlait tout à
l'heure
autour d'un petit café.
Autour d'un petit café. Le problème des
réseaux sociaux, c'est à la fois une
arme exceptionnelle pour s'informer et à
la fois très compliquée puisque
l'algorithme
Pourquoi tu as dit une arme ? parce que
c'est une arme le pour moi les réseaux
sociaux, que ce soit Twitter, TikTok,
euh Instagram,
Facebook un peu moins parce queon est
vraiment encore dans un autre truc. Euh
même YouTube, c'est pour moi euh une
arme d'information. C'est c'est un
outil, jeurais pu dire outil mais pour
moi c'est une arme. C'est plus une arme
parce que ça te sert. Euh aujourd'hui,
tu le vois il y a pas très longtemps, il
y a un mec qui a eu une amende parce
qu'il a échangé sa place avec un autre
mec euh dans le train.
C'était peut-être une nana d'ailleurs.
C'est une nana, je ne sais plus. En tout
cas, il y a eu un souci. Ça a fait
tellement parler sur Twitter que la la
SNCF s'est cru s'est dit "Oh là, OK les
gars, on va rembourser." Donc parfois
quand il y a un mouvement général sur un
réseau social et qui a j'appelle pas ça
un buz parce que pour moi un buz c'est
autre chose mais quand il reste sur le
coup une unité et c'est là où on voit
qu'on est vraiment beaucoup plus fort
quand on est solidaire en tout cas quand
il y a un élan de solidarité comme ça
les lignes bougent. Donc pour moi, les
réseaux sociaux, c'est à la fois super.
Mais ce qui est très compliqué pour
s'informer, c'est que moi qui suis
plutôt de gauche et plutôt euh, je vais
toujours avoir dans mon fil des gens qui
pensent comme moi, qui disent à peu près
les mêmes choses que moi, donc qui ont
les mêmes façons de penser, la
politique, même le cinéma, même la télé
et cetera. Or, si j'étais euh plutôt de
droite, ça serait pareil. Donc du coup,
tu es alimenté toute la journée par un
fil qui te donne ce que tu dois manger,
ce que tu aimes manger. Du coup, tu ne
vas jamais goûter ailleurs. Donc ce qui
est important, je trouve, c'est d'aller
chercher des sites ou des des gens un
peu comme euh Sinkerview, par exemple.
Comment tu as entendu parler de nous ?
Euh je pense que c'est quelqu'un qui a
dû vous retweeter un jour et j'ai été
voir
encore quelqu'un de gauche ça.
Probablement quelqu'un de gauche et j'ai
été voir et j'ai vu que quand même euh
c'était quand même assez sourcé, c'était
assez bien fait. Il y a quand même des
choses euh voilà, j'aime beaucoup les
jours par exemple. Les jours c'est un
journal sur leur site, tu t'abonnes et
ils font des dossiers, ils font des
enquêtes. J'aime bien Mediapart parce
que Miaappart c'est sourcé. Après, tu
peux aimer ou pas être WNL et le
problème n'est pas là. Je me fiche. Moi,
ce que je vois, c'est le résultat. C'est
exactement comme complément d'enquête.
Les mecs font des enquêtes. Le Alors,
ils sont totalement
euh euh dénués de on va prendre partie
ou pas. Nous, on fait une enquête.
Voilà. Bon, mais c'est très difficile d'
Élise aussi.
Élise, évidemment. Mais euh c'est dur
aujourd'hui si tu as vraiment envie de
manger toute la journée les mêmes infos
et qu'on te conforte dans ta façon de
penser en étant sur les réseaux sociaux
et non en allant pas chercher plus loin.
Comment tu fais toi pour aller chercher
plus J'essaie de voir les gens plus
intelligents que moi, euh
les sites qui vont voir, à quoi ils sont
abonnés, comment ça se passe et j'essaie
de trouver des sites où il y a des
vraies sources, où il y a des vrais des
bonnes cages et où au moins il y a un
petit panel qui t'explique de façon plus
posée. Euh et puis aujourd'hui
l'emballement médiatique, il est dingue.
C'est il se passe un truc, tu as même
pas le temps de finir lactu que déjà il
y a 200 informations de 200 trucs
différents qui disent chacun leur truc
et c'est un bordel sans nom.
Est-ce que les gens autour de toi ils se
confient tes fans ou les gens que qui
peuvent te suivre ? Est-ce que quand tu
te balades dans la rue des fois tu
entames les discussions sur ce qui se
passe dans le monde ? Qu'est-ce qui te
font remonter les gens autour de toi ?
Même si ça
Moi, j'ai eu beaucoup Ouais. J'ai eu
beaucoup de gens qui m'ont arrêté dans
la rue quand j'avais quand j'avais parlé
du fait que moi j'ai subi des des
violences avec mon ex-mari et cetera et
les il y a beaucoup de femmes qui m'ont
écrit, qui m'ont accosté dans la rue
pour me demander comment je m'en étais
sortie, qui elle devait aller voir,
comment elle pouvait se faire aider et
cetera. Beaucoup. Et c'est vrai que moi
j'ai je réponds très souvent. Après,
j'ai des gens dans la rue qui me
demandent où acheter une lampe ou du
plac hein. Ça c'est vrai aussi. Mais
c'est vrai que non, très souvent il y a
des gens beaucoup de gens m'ont parlé de
mon interview chez Clic. J'ai fait une
interview chez Clic où j'ai parlé de mon
agacement à propos de l'affaire de par
Dieu. Euh et j'ai donc reparlé aussi des
violences conjugales que j'avais moi
subi. Et c'est vrai que les gens ont
beaucoup vu cette cette interview comme
quoi tu vois les réseaux sociaux parce
que clic à la télé, c'est très peu de
spectateurs. Là où c'est énormément
relayé, énormément vu, c'est sur les
réseaux sociaux.
On passe la bise à Mouloude.
On passe la bise à Mouloue que j'aime
beaucoup. Mais donc oui, c'est vrai
qu'il y a plein de gens qui m'ont dit
qui me parlent beaucoup de de tout de ce
que moi je peux dire sur les femmes, les
mecs, les violences conjugales. Euh très
souvent, comme je défends pas mal les
profs, les services publics, c'est vrai
qu'il y a des profs qui m'arrêtent. Oh
là là, merci hein, parce que
franchement, on en a marre. Bah je
comprends les gars, c'est compliqué.
Donc
voilà. Quel regard tu portes sur Macron
et sur François Hollande dans le sens
que tu veux ?
Moi, j'ai voté François Hollande donc ça
je
personne n'est parfaite.
Personne n'est parfait. Moi je suis
traditionnellement plutôt en train de
vouloir voter vers la gauche qui m'a
l'air plutôt d'être toujours vers
l'empathie, le social, le la protection
des services publics, la discussion, le
dialogue.
Un peu de caviar.
Oh, un peu de caviar. J'en sais rien.
J'aime pas le caviar. Mais bon, moi j'ai
grandi argenteuil, j'ai grandi dans une
famille populaire. J'ai toujours entendu
mes parents dire
Genteuil c'est Sanois tout ça.
Sanoir Genteuil. Bah oui, Franconville,
la pâtinoire.
Beson.
Beson. Ouais. Ouille. Bon,
carrière
au mieux carrière mais c'était les
riches carrières. Mais mais du coup si
tu veux, je veux bien voter à gauche.
Mais là en vrai Macron
euh Beson.
On embrasse Beson, Vesou et Argenteuil.
Euh donc
Macron.
Ouais Macron si tu veux, j'ai
l'impression qu'il est
seul, tu sais. Il y a un personnage dans
Astérix, un petit gamin qui quand il
s'énerve, il fait il arrête de respirer.
Je ne sais plus son nom. Peut-être les
gens qui nous regardent retrouveront son
nom. Il fait
sou l'onion et croûon. Voilà, il
s'énerve et il arrête de respirer quand
on n'écoute pas ce qu'il dit.
J'ai l'impression que Emmanuel Macron,
il est un petit peu comme ce personnage.
C'està dire que je le sens très seul. Je
sens qu'il est seul à prendre des
décisions. Il doit pas écouter beaucoup
les gens autour de lui. J'ai pas
l'impression qu'il écoute beaucoup les
Français.
Il est peut-être mal conseillé. Non,
ça j'en sais rien. Mais en tout cas, je
pense que il est toujours en train de
dire qu'il veut parler aux gens. Mais
moi, je trouve qu'il a une façon
terrible de parler aux gens. Du travail.
Traverser la rue, je vais vous en
trouver.
cette espèce de façon toujours
condescendante de parler aux gens comme
si les gens qui n'avaient pas de travail
étaient des sales feignants et qui
s'encroûtaient là-dedans. Peut-être
hein, il y a des gens qui adorent être
au chômage et qui kiffent ne gagner que
dalle par par mois. Je les connais pas
ces gens-là. Moi, je connais plein de
gens au chômage qui sont en dépression,
qui sont malheureux, qui sont qui sont
pas bien.
Donc il a toujours une façon de parler
mais il a l'impression que c'est la
bonne. Tu dis "Bah non, en fait,
j'aimerais que tu passes un peu de temps
avec des vrais gens. euh et que tu
saches comment parler aux gens. Je
trouve qu'il a une façon très très
compliquée de parler et a lui
l'impression que c'est la bonne et qu'en
tout cas les gens le comprennent pas du
tout. Je crois pas. Et j'aimerais
d'ailleurs que les présidents, les
hommes politiques, les ministres soient
des gens qui viennent pas de de grandes
écoles mais qui viennent
d'endroit où ils ont bossé. Travaille,
gagne ta vie, gagne ta croûte. Euh et tu
vas voir, obéir à des ordres d'un
patron, arrive à l'heure, pointe euh et
tu vas voir la vie elle va te paraître
totalement différente. Galère pour
trouver un médecin, euh galère aux
urgences de l'hôpital parce que
forcément euh que ce soit un député, un
ministre et cetera, personne ne fait la
queue aux urgences, hein. Tout le monde
a un médecin, un pote, un truc, un
machin. Et donc j'aimerais qu' que que
avant d'arriver au pouvoir, on ait des
gens qui nous dirigent qui soient passé
par la vraie vie en fait, qui est
vraiment vécu avec un salaire minimum,
un loyer à payer, un patron à écouter,
un travail à rendre en temps et en
heure. Et peut-être que à ce moment-là,
on aurait des gens qui respecteraient
plus les Français. En tout cas, je pense
que ça serait comme ça. Là, je trouve
qu'en plus, on va vers un petit
problème. Trump va sûrement repasser.
Euh pour moi, c'est
J'arrive même pas à capter comment ce
gars est encore sur le devant de la
scène. Mais bon, c'est apparemment
Pourquoi tu arrives pas à capter ?
Mais ce gars est complètement fou en
fait. Il a
On s'en fout du gars.
Ah bah parce que je me dis mais
comment il arrive à convaincre les
foules ?
Mais je ne sais pas, c'est une énigme
pour moi. Tu vois, je me dis ces gens
ont eu 4 ans ou combien de temps il est
resté ? 4 ans ou 5 ans, je sais plus que
moi c'est 4 ans chez eux hein. Il a
quand même fait un peu de merde. Il a
quand même fait régresser les droits que
ce soit les droits des femmes, la façon
enfin tu dis donc OK, ils ont supporté
ça pendant 4 ans, mais à quel moment
avec toutes les casseroles qu'il peut
avoir derrière lui, tu dis mais donc
vous allez il repasse encore dans les
primaires, il passe en tête. Mais quel
est le le le but de ces gens qui votent
pour lui ? La rage,
la rage, j'entends. Mais il a rien fait
pour sauver les gens qui avaient déjà la
rage à l'époque. Ça a été encore plus la
rage. Donc je je te jure des fois je me
dis comme des des fois j'entends des
gens qui disent "Bis
eu l'extrême brotte au pouvoir. Bah oui,
j'ai jamais mangé mon caca, je m'en
pororte pas plus mal." Enfin, tu vois,
c'est moi les comparaisons comme ça, des
fois, je me dis "Oh les gars,
non mais et on fait pas de comparaison
caca et ainsi de suite parce que j'ueule
les mecs de droite qui posent devant moi
qui font des comparaisons.
Alors, je dirais et ben j'ai jamais
mangé de pigeon cru et pour autant ma
vie va très bien." Enfin, tu vois, c'est
toujours compliqué les les trucs comme
ça. Donc moi, je me dis
Emmanuel Macron, je pense qu'il est seul
en fait et qu' voilà, j'ai l'impression,
je le vois dans sa tour d'ivoire.
Euh pensez qu'il est le meilleur, pensez
qu'il a la parole absolue. Tu
as voté Macron ?
Bah j'ai voté Macron parce que moi je ne
peux pas m'abstenir de voter quand il y
a le Front National en face. Un vote
blanc.
Mais c'est si c'était reconnu le vote
blanc, je voterai blanc. Mais ce n'est
pas reconnu. J'adorerais pouvoir voter
blanc. Me dire "Ah et ben non, ni l'un
ni l'autre. Peste choléra vote blanc."
Hitler Hitler.
Ah vousou là ? Ah je sais pas. Allez je
vais faire une raclette. Euh
ça n'existe pas le vote blanc. Donc euh
et moi je ne sais pas, je trouve que
voter c'est un moi j'ai j'encourage
vachement les jeunes à voter. Pour moi
voter c'est un tel droit. Euh alors
surtout pour nous les femmes, on a eu le
droit de voter beaucoup plus tard que
vous. Euh donc euh je me dis voter c'est
vraiment
Et tu sais pourquoi ?
Bon parce que faut pas voter. Les femmes
sont bêtes. Donc les hommes ont voulu
qu'on
C'est fait comme ça. Après on peut vous
imposer.
C'est vrai. C'est pas c'est pas faux
parce qu'avant vous étiez pas imposé.
C'est vrai. Tu as raison. Et on a même
pas checké. Alors
même pas de compte en banque monsieur
mais
fallait demander à ton mari au mari et
pop et encore
ou là qu'est-ce que c'est que cette
indépendance que tu réclames là ?
Un compte en banque à ton nom mais dis
donc
mais qu'est-ce que tu en ferais ?
Mais jeune viève enfin pourquoi faire ?
Non, c'est c'est compliqué parce que je
me dis les jeunes faut vraiment
s'inscrire, faut vraiment voter. C'est
un vrai truc parce que c'est eux
l'avenir, c'est pas les mecs de plus de
70 ans. J'ai lu récemment dans un très
très bon article que l'électorat de
Macron, ils avaient plus de 60 ans.
Où ça ?
Euh, j'ai lu ça sur
le Huffington Post
une parfaite prononciation.
Hington Post, tu veux que je te le fasse
à l'américaine ou pas ? Et je me dis
donc l'électorat de Macron a plus de 60
ans, la jeunesse, allez-y. Alors,
j'imagine qu'il une partie de la
jeunesse qui va voter certainement à
droite. Enfin, tu vois, chacun ses
convictions.
Mais les jeunes devraient voter
Mélenchon
ou je sais pas Mélenchon.
Pourquoi tu sais pas Mélenchon ? Bah
parce que Mélenchon, même si les je
crois qu'il y a une partie des gens qui
aimeraient voter à gauche à qui
Mélenchon fait un peu peur. Je pense que
la République, c'est moi, ça a fait
beaucoup de mal à
au propos. Tu vois ce que je veux dire ?
C'est un peu compliqué. Moi, j'aime bien
les gens qui ont des convictions, qui
défendent les droits et les services
publics. Mais la République, c'est moi.
Moi, ça m'a tendu un peu cette phrase.
Gabriel Tal.
Gabriel Atal, il a pour à tout principal
je pense sa jeunesse. Les gens doivent
se dire "Mon dieu, il est jeune, c'est
super."
Gabriel Atal, il a été ministre de
l'éducation nationale,
que s'est-il passé ? Bah rien en fait,
hein. Après, il a mis Amélie Castagette
et maintenant on a Nicole Béoubé. Que de
modernité.
Comment tu dis ?
C'est Thomas VDB qui m'a fait rire. Il
l'a appelé avec un un comique
pardon
qui m'a fait beaucoup rire. Il l'a
appelé euh Amélie Castagnette, enfin il
l'a appelé de plein de noms. Ça m'a fait
beaucoup rire. Euh je pense que Gabriel
Attal, écoute, il est jeune.
Voilà. Ben c'est Est-ce que ça suffit ?
Stéphane Séjourné, c'est qui ?
Ben c'est notre ministre des affaires
étrangères. Donc
il est jeune aussi, c'est super. Moi
j'aime bien l'idée d'avoir des gens
jeunes mais après
il a beaucoup de courage quand même.
Il a beaucoup de courage mais après
il a il a pas d'expérience dans le
domaine de la diplomatie. Il a été
parachuté là parce que il avait
peut-être besoin d'un homme de confiance
à la tête de ce ministère-là. Et et
bah surtout il y avait peut-être encore
plus pas trop de candidats qui avaient
envie de faire partie du gouvernement.
Je pense que là ils ont été un petit peu
euh c'est compliqué. Je sais pas qui
veut rentrer dans ce gouvernement. C'est
tu tu rentres au gouvernement et tu
prends déjà un upercute de Mike Tyson en
pleine face. tu es ministre. Donc bon,
plus personne n'a envie d'y aller. Euh
je pense que la jeunesse c'est pas le
tout. C'est super d'être jeune. Mais
quand j'écoute des fois Gabriel Atal
parler qui nous parle de d'uniforme de
de trucs, je fais wou même mon père qui
est qui est mort, il parlait pas comme
ça. Et et
je me dis c'est compliqué. C'est
est-ce qu'il écoute bien la jeunesse et
toute la jeunesse, je sais pas. Euh
est-ce qu'il a déjà été jeune ?
Je sais pas. Bah écoute,
comment tu vois l'avenir pour tes
enfants ? Ah ça moi ça me fait souci
parce que
je vois euh
mon fils bosse dans la restauration, ma
fille elle est illustratrice.
Il bosse vachement les deux pour s'en
sortir. Euh ils ont des loyers, ils sont
dans des des 20 m² à 900 balles par mois
à Paris. Ma fille et mon fils tous les
deux, ils veulent pas rester à Paris.
Pour l'instant, c'est là où ils gagnent
leur vie, mais je pense qu'à terme, ils
ont envie de se barrer de Paris qui est
une ville très chère euh et très
compliqué.
Moi, je vois l'avenir très compliqué.
Ils ont pas envie d'avoir un enfant
parce que bah
qui a envie de faire des enfants dans ce
contexte là ? C'est extrêmement
anxiogène. Et
je je je sais pas, je suis inquiète.
Alors, tant que je vivrai, je serai là
pour eux. Mais euh c'est moi je je suis
je suis admirative des jeunes qui
continuent à lutter, à faire des études,
à essayer de s'en sortir. Moi je trouve
qu'on a une jeunesse.
Tu vois ton fils partir à la guerre ?
Ah bah non, moi je suis, tu sais, moi je
suis pas du tout pour la guerre. C'est
un truc compliqué pour moi la guerre. La
guerre pour moi, c'est vraiment un truc
on fait la guerre quand on sait plus
quoi faire économiquement. Ça relance
l'économie. Euh toutes les guerres,
toutes les histoires de guerre, ça a
toujours été comme ça. Oh non, c'est un
peu la merde. On pourra faire la guerre.
Euh les trucs de de
où on va provoquer la guerre.
Où on va provoquer la guerre. En tout
cas, la guerre c'est toujours une façon
euh détournée de de de
Moi, je suis pas du tout euh pour la
guerre. J'entends par contre que la
situation en Ukraine, elle est très
compliquée, que tu peux pas du tout
mais par contre, tu peux pas dire à
Poutine e dis donc, c'est pas bien.
Parce que le gars, il fait comme ça,
arrêtez de vous batter.
Arrêtez de vous batter parce que tu le
mec, il fait comme hein, tu quoi ? Mais
je t'emmerde, j'ai plein de d'ogives
nucléaires qui vont partir sur ta
tronche. Le mec est tellement puissant,
tellement d'armes.
Donc je moi je crois beaucoup à la
négociation, au dialogue, à la
discussion. Maintenant tu peux pas le
laisser jouer et dire tiens, je vais
annexer ce pays. La semaine prochaine,
j'en ferai un autre. Tu dis W oui, c'est
c'est très tendu, c'est très compliqué.
Euh maintenant effectivement euh si
demain euh si ce soir à 20h euh le
président nous annonce que c'est la
guerre et que euh il faut partir là-bas
euh ah pour moi c'est très compliqué. Je
c'est moi qui suis pas du tout pour la
guerre ça.
Qu'est-ce que tu feras s'il annonce la
guerre ce soir ?
Bah qu'est-ce que tu veux que je fasse ?
C'est c'est malheureux mais je ne dirige
pas le pays. Je ne peux pas contrer
monsieur Macron.
J'espère que
moi je crois toujours à la diplomatie et
au dialogue. Je je n'arrive pas à à
croire qu'on ne peut pas trouver une
solution. Euh
dans tous les conflits euh euh il faut
toujours essayer de trouver euh la
négociation, le dialogue. Alors, je sais
qu'il y a des des gens avec qui on ne
peut rien faire et c'est très compliqué,
mais moi c'est la guerre, ça me
Moi, j'ai eu des parents et des
grands-parents qui ont connu la guerre
et qui m'en ont pas dit que du bien en
fait. Et après, si tu lis un peu
l'histoire, tu vois que la guerre c'est
pas le truc le mieux. C'est très bien
pour l'économie hein, mais c'est pas
très bien pour la population en fait
hein. C'est
très bien pour l'économie quand tu
gagnes.
Quand tu gagnes bien sûr. Bah quand tu
perds, tu es pas bien. Mais euh
Non, c'est moi je trouve que c'est on
vit dans un moment très douloureux, très
compliqué, très anxiogène.
Euh
là, je fais des dates en province de mon
spectacle.
Où ça ?
Euh bah là, en ce moment, c'est un peu
la pause là. fin mai, j'ai une date mais
là en ce moment je ne je
Il va faire la causette avec nous.
Je vais faire la causette avec SV SW. Je
à chaque fois je
dira français
view.
Exactement.
Tuas tu un curview. Je me dis toujours à
chaque fois à la fin des spectacles
quand on comme je fais du standup et que
je suis beaucoup dans l'actu.
Ça parle de quoi ? Bon, ça raconte ma
vie et en même temps, on fait plein de
petites vannes sur l'ctu. On hm je peux
pas m'en empêcher. Euh et les gens une
bah je dis mon père était Flic et je
disais Flic euh gendarme ou Flic Flic
? Non non, Flic était commissaire de
police.
Où ça ? Euh
à Colombe.
À Colombe. Euh donc 94 92
92 pardon. Orlie ? Non non, colombe,
colombe
colombe colomb
et dans le spectacle, je dis bah moi
quand j'étais petite, je voyais mon
père, je voulais être flic comme lui. B
mono, tac tac badaboum mon petit cuir
hop monter sur l'étoile, l'hélicoptère.
Mais en fait, c'est pas ça quoi.
Aujourd'hui, la carrière d'un flic,
c'est plutôt genre
32 km/h trottinette et puis finir ma
carrière sous les ordres de Darmanin.
Enfin, quand je dis sous les ordres, si
j'écoute BFM, c'est plutôt sous le
bureau. Enfin, tu vois, je fais des
vannes comme ça et cetera. Bon et à la
fin, tu as toujours les gens qui
viennent me voir et me disent "Ouais,
c'est dur." Tu vois, beaucoup j'ai
beaucoup de profs qui viennent me voir
en spectacle.
Qui me disait "Ah, c'est compliqué,
comment on va faire ?" Les gens sont
largués, ils sont pas bien. Et je
comprends parce que voir la sortie du
spectacle. Bien sûr, parce que moi
j'aime bien faire des photos, signer des
trucs,
taper la bise.
Taper la bise. Euh non, c'est c'est là
pour continuer à avoir de l'énergie, de
l'envie, euh le smile euh c'est
waouh, c'est chaud.
Comment tu trouves la couverture
médiatique des conflits ?
toujours pareil, c'est euh
tu te dis "Mais à quel moment ?" Donc
OK, vous nous montrez tous les conflits
que ce soit en Palestine, que ce soit en
Ukraine euh
mais personne ne va vraiment sur place
en fait.
Il y a pas de enfin on a des
ça devient très compliqué de couvrir un
conflit de voà. Ça devent compliqué.
Avant, il y avait des reporters de
guerre. Bon, c'était le métier.
Il y a des tours opérateurs pour
maintenant il y a il y a d'autres choses
mais
c'est très dur. On est vraiment dans la
guerre de l'info, dans la guerre de
l'image, dans la guerre des réseaux euh
dans la dans la propagande parce que
de tous les côtés, de toute façon, tu ne
sais pas. À moins d'avoir un mec sur
place euh qui est euh local, qui vit
là-bas, qui est journaliste et qui te
donne les bonnes infos, c'est on est
vraiment la guerre de l'info et les
avant c'était un métier hein et c'était
un sale métier. Reporter de de guerre,
les gars, ils y allaient quoi. Euh connu
des reporters de guerre, ouais, qui ont
fini paradis parce qu'ils avaient plus
de boulot. Euh il y a un très bon film
qui s'appelle Harrison Flowers
d'ailleurs sur les reporters de guerre.
Euh tu as aussi euh un super film qui
s'appelle Salvador sur les reporters de
guerre euh avec James Wood qui est là
qui est à New York qui veut absolument
couvrir les conflits. Crac crac. Enfin
c'est c'est un métier de
Tu as l'impression qu'il y a un double
standard dans la gestion et
l'information des des conflits. Quand on
voit ce qui se passe en Ukraine, quand
on voit ce qui se passe en Palestine ou
en Israël,
euh comment tu déjà tu analyses ce que
tu peux recevoir ? Est-ce que tu vas
chercher derrière ? Est-ce que tu vas
trianguler ton information ? Est-ce que
tu as des copains ensuite qui sont sur
place ? Est-ce que tu fais ça ?
Moi, j'ai pas de copains sur place et je
regrette.
Moi, je déjà le le le conflit euh
israélo-palestinien
est un tel
et tellement compliqué et tellement
larvé depuis des années et des années,
on a la Palestine dirigée par un des
terroristes qui maltraitent la
population, qui maltraitent le monde
entier.
Euh en face, tu as Netaniaou qui n'est
pas le roi de la négociation, qui est
plutôt vers la droite du conflit, qui
est plutôt très sévère. Donc tu as des
fous en Palestine et tu as quelqu'un de
très dur en face. Donc le conflit c'est
très dur à régler. Il faudrait qu'il ait
quelqu'un d'extérieur euh truc qui
s'appellerait l'ONU par exemple qui qui
arrêterait et qui dirait "Oh alors déjà
les terroristes là dehors, on va
dialoguer, on va essayer de trouver la
paix pour tout le monde. On peut pas
laisser des enfants mourir de faim, on
peut pas laisser des civils se faire
massacrer et on ne peut pas laisser de
l'autre côté des civils se faire enlever
euh violer, assassiner. C'est n'importe
quoi. Enfin, je veux dire, c'est une
folie. Donc euh tu te dis euh moi j'ai
beaucoup de peine pour les civils qui se
retrouvent au milieu de tout ça qui
n'ont rien fait et qui se retrouve des
deux côtés en train de pleurer euh en
Israël les otages plus personne n'a de
nouvelle. Moi, je me mets à la place des
familles. Je me dis mais mais moi je
serais je sais je sais même pas comment
ils tiennent. Euh et de l'autre côté,
les civils qui se font bombarder et qui
voient leurs enfants mourir. C'est fou,
tout est tout est tellement horrible.
Tout est tellement
La France au milieu de tout ça, tu
trouves que la France joue son rôle ?
Bah je Tu sais alors si tu écoutes tout
le monde et la France continue d'envoyer
des armes, tu ne sais pas qui, tu ne
sais pas. Moi, je ne suis pas du tout ni
géopoliticienne. Je moi ce que je vois
c'est qu'il y a des gens qui souffrent
des deux côtés et que et que les civils,
les familles, les enfants des deux côtés
n'ont pas à supporter une situation
pareille parce que des fous dirigent un
pays. Euh c'est des terroristes
bah foutent la merde dans un pays et
empêchent les gens de vivre normalement.
Euh pour moi, le terrorisme n'est pas
n'est pas une entité qui est capable de
gouverner un pays
inversement pareil hein. C'estàd que
et de l'autre côté tu peux tu es obligé
d'avoir il faut dialoguer, il faut
essayer de retrouver. Alors moi j'ai pas
la solution, je ne suis je ne suis pas
je ne suis personne. Moi mon ressenti
c'est la souffrance des familles. Moi,
je me mets à la place des familles de
deux côtés. Je trouve ça terrible. Euh
et en Ukraine, c'est pareil. tu vois des
gens qui sont dans leur pays euh qui
sont obligés de se sauver parce que le
mec a décidé qu'il allait agrandir son
pays à lui. Tu fais
et c'est et rien n'avance. Ça fait quand
même
Ça dure
ça 2 ans.
Bah ça on rentre dans la 3e année là.
Donc tu te dis euh
ces gens ne vont jamais retrouver une
vie normale.
Tu as peur du conflit nucléaire ? Bah je
pense que Poutine est suffisamment euh
tu vois euh vous me cherchez
tu vois il y a un moment donné euh oui
ça peut être une enfin tu vois je ne
pense pas que la guerre ça sera avec euh
l'infanterie comme en 141 ou en 39 40
avec des chars et oui il y aura sûrement
un peu d'infanterie il y en a déjà mais
je dire si le mec il a vraiment envie de
d'arrêter le
c'est c'est très compliqué Ouais, c'est
un truc qui fait peur quand même. Tu tu
sens bien que le mec ne lâche rien et
que il a pas envie de lâcher.
Tu as refait la décou du bunker de
l'Élysée ou pas ?
Oh mon dieu, quel enfer ! Non non non.
Mais est-ce qu'il faut vraiment faire la
déco d'un bunker ? Je préférais faire la
déco
des nouveaux immeubles qui seraient
construits à la place des passoirs
énergétiques dans les cités par exemple.
Ça ça m'arrangerait bien. Ouais. Il y a
pas que dans les cités qu'il y a des
passours énergétiques.
Ouais, mais beaucoup dans les cités, je
te le dis, hein. Hm hm. Il y en a
beaucoup beaucoup. Tous ces immeubles
euh et toutes ces cités qui ont été
construites dans les années 60 là, 70
aujourd'hui
Ah ouais. Et il y en a plus le même prix
du FU ou du gaz. C'est compliqué. On va
parler un peu immobilier, rénovation,
tout ça un peu. Après, on continue un
peu sur ta perception par exemple de
Bruno Lemire.
Quelle est quelle est la personne du
gouvernement que tu kiffes le plus ?
là de ce gouvernement-là déjà.
Sérieusement ?
Ah ben trouve-moisen un.
Ah là ça va être
ministre de l'écologie,
comment il s'appelle ?
Monsieur bras croisé. Euh
même pas même pas un
sincèrement je cherche làin. Euh
OK. Un politique que tu aimes bien ?
Bah moi j'aime bien
George Marchais.
Geen marchais. Pauvre. Euh écoute euh
moi j'aimais bien euh j'aimais bien
Benoît Among si
non je rigole. Là dans le paysage
politique quand il parle je trouve qu'il
dit toujours des choses intéressantes.
J'aime bien l'écouter parler c'est
rufin. Après euh
il a sûrement des défauts que je ne
connais pas mais en tout cas quand il
parle je comprends ce qu'il me dit. Je
trouve que c'est toujours logique. Je
trouve que c'est toujours bienveillant
et c'est toujours très humaniste. Donc
j'aime bien écouter Ruffin. Après Bruno
Lemer pour moi c'est tellement le
renflement brun que
quoi ? Bah tu sais, il a écrit un livre
porno dans lequel il dit que ça.
Ah bah je t'en supplie, il faut que
Tu l'as lu ?
Non non, j'ai lu extrait ça me Tu
étais pas émoustillé ?
Non
même pas.
Pourtant il a un physique d'Apollon. Il
est beau. C'est un beau mec. Il a des
yeux bleus. Il s reconnaît un amenttin.
Euh
Bruno Lemè est beau mec.
Il est beau mec Bruno Lemire.
Alors moi tu sais c'est plutôt mon genre
de mec c'est plutôt Aquaman tu sais.
Jason Moma tout ça les mecs un peu avec
les cheveux longs brun tu vois un peu
pont
Bruno Lemè oui faut un coup de terme de
finance il fait du bon boulot
bah non il taxe pas les riches donc
c'est pas possible en fait de vouloir
sans arrêt taxer les petits.
Pourquoi il taxent pas les riches à ton
avis ? Tu sais, il y a une arlésienne
qui revient tout le temps, c'est la taxe
la loi toobine là, tu sais où tu
taxerais les transactions financières et
cetera, cette espèce d'arlésienne de
taxe qui on ne voit jamais et qui
pourtant rapporterait des millions.
Je sais pas pourquoi on taxe pas les
riches pour pas les fâcher. Parce que
c'est des gros investisseurs, parce que
parce qu'on joue au golf ensemble, j'en
sais rien. En tout cas, on les taxe pas.
Ça c'est une certitude.
J'adore he savoir que il y a des gens
qui gagnent très bien leur vie et moi je
trouve ça génial. Une fois de plus, je
n'ai rien contre les riches. Je me fous
éperdument. J'adore ça, la réussite,
l'argent, je trouve ça génial. Mais
quand tu gagnes énormément, faut payer à
la hauteur. Là, récemment, je lisais que
euh Airbnb ne payait pas ses impôts. Il
nous manque, ils ont 300 millions de de
d'impôts qui sont pas
C'est quoi la source ?
Euh c'est quoi la source ? Bah, bonne
question. Ça doit être ou le monde ou
peut-être l'B ou tu vois, en tout cas,
c'est un journal.
Tu dis bah pourquoi faut les faut faut
les c'est bien quand je vois qu'on
dépense. Donc ça nous a coûté entre 2 et
3 milliards le SNU.
Non. Tu es sûr ?
Ouais. H Et oui.
Et oui. Pour faire quoi ?
Esprit de corps, de cohésion de faire
corps.
Fernation.
Fernation. Ouais.
Chanter l'hymne national à la levée des
couleurs.
Ouais. Moi, je trouve qu'on est très
beau.
Faire son lit au carré.
Ouais. Ouais, je trouve qu'on est très
beau quand on est ensemble mais je crois
qu'il y a d'autres trucs pour se réunir
que l'uniforme et le et le SNU.
On parle un peu maison immobilier déco.
Quand tu es primo accédent, quand tu es
jeune et que tu veux acheter un TODI
énergétique et que il y a une inflation
sur les matières premières qui te
permettent d'isoler, de reconstruire,
comment ça va le marché de l'immobilier
en ce moment ? Écoute, je suis pas dans
l'immobilier mais euh moi qui essaie de
vendre désespérément ma maison pour me
casser euh dans les bois euh bah c'est
compliqué. C'est très compliqué. Euh
tu es obligé de baisser ton prix là ? Ah
oui, mais de toute façon euh il faut
enfin tu vois euh c'est euh je pense que
c'est aujourd'hui si tu veux acheter une
maison ou un appartement à un prix
raisonnable déjà il faut que soit tu as
déjà l'argent de côté parce que ta
famille t'a prêté soit tu as bien
économisé parce que si tu veux faire un
crédit à la banque avec les taux de
crédit en ce moment
reste chez toi plutôt euh
quand ton dossier est accepté. quand ton
dossier est accepté bien évidemment. Euh
non, c'est je pense que là la crise de
l'immobilier, elle ne fait que démarrer
et malheureusement je pense que les
passoirs énergétiques, elles sont encore
là pour des années. Personne jamais ne
va déjà, faudrait reloger tous les gens
qui vivent dans ces passoirs
énergétiques.
Les reloger où ? On construit plus rien
de d'abord. En tout cas, les
constructions qui sont faites
aujourd'hui, c'est très cher. Donc plus
ça va, plus les gens qui n'ont pas les
moyens, on les éloigne de la capitale.
Ils vont de plus en plus loin et même en
allant de plus en plus loin, ça reste
quand même cher.
Euh
moi, je suis pour aller vivre dans les
bois les gars. Et
la capitale,
faut la quitter.
Tu vois tu tu vas faire plaisir à
Nidalgo
et Anniealgo, tu aimes bien Annie
Hidalgo ? Gentille. Écoute, moi je fais
du vélo donc du sourire tout le temps.
Moi, je fais du vélo. Je sais bien
pistes de vélo. Euh
moi je pense que là on est enfin c'est
aujourd'hui moi quand je vois le prix
que des des loyers mais
tu te dis mais euh
ma fille 947 € pour 20
charge comprise ou pas ? charge
comprise. Non, tu sais à l'année à la
fin de l'année, on te fait un petit un
petit réassort euh pour 22 m², tu fais
euh
C'est beaucoup quand même
avec ascenseur sans ascenseur ?
Non, 6e sans ascenseur, tu es fou.
Et les toilettes sur le palier ?
Non, pas exagéré. Mais euh tu te dis euh
mais qui peut louer ça ?
C'est c'est dur. C'est très très dur.
Donc je pense que là c'est
Est-ce que quand tu refais des décos, on
te demande de faire de la déco qui peut
isoler un peu ?
Bah oui, mais le problème de la déco qui
isole, bah c'est si par exemple tu mets
du placot avec de l'isolon derrière sur
une dans une passoire énergétique,
imaginons, bah déjà tu pars tu perds de
l'espace hein, parce que l'isolant plus
le plac, on est on est parti pour perdre
20 cm,
c'est beaucoup. Et puis c'est un petit
pensement sur une grosse coupure.
C'est-à-dire que oui, ça va isoler un
petit peu, mais enfin très rapidement le
c'est quand tu mets de la peinture sans
sous-couche quoi. Au bout d'un moment ça
se ça s'écaille à nouveau. Bah là c'est
pareil. Non, il y a vraiment c'est c'est
un puissant fond là l'immobilier. Si
vraiment fallait refaire tous les
immeubles, les maisons euh qui sont des
passoirs énergétiques.
Est-ce que le gouvernement Est-ce que tu
suis un petit peu ce que fait le
gouvernement pour les primos accédents,
les rénovations de passoir énergétiques,
les normes pour l'écologie, les normes
pour le chauffage, les normes pour
l'électricité ?
Bah je suis déjà le gouvernement sur le
recul en matière d'écologie, mais bon,
on a des touillettes en carton.
Qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise ?
La dernière fois, je sors les
je sors les poubelles de recyclage, tu
sais, de carton de papier et je parle
avec le mec et il me dit euh bah vous
savez queon sait plus où les [__]
hein, il y a plus de place hein, donc on
fout tout pareil hein. Ah d'accord. Bah
c'est super de trier alors. Non mais tu
te dis que en matière d'écologie, on est
tellement loin, on s'est fait encore
taper sur la gueule par tout le monde.
On ne va pas assez loin. On sait tous
que c'est la merde là, le réchauffement
climatique et cetera. Alors avant quand
on disait ça, on passait pour un
complotiste ou un fou. Donc maintenant
on y est là, ça y est. Mais il y a des
gens qui continuent à dire "Ouais, ça va
mais non Trump le premier qui te dit
mais non" tu dis "Bah si les gars, on
est mal, on est mal, on mange trop de
viande, on fait trop d'élevage,
on fait trop de puis alors et les méga
bassines et les et les et les autoroutes
gigantesques avec et tu te dis "Oh mais
ça va s'arrêter où Qu'est-ce qui te m
rage le plus en ce moment mis à part ce
qu'on a abordé
de voir que des gens comme les
soulèvements de la terre sont traités
comme des terroristes
alors qu'ils essayent de sauver ce qu'il
y a à sauver. Euh moi ça me fend le
cœur. Je trouve qu'on ne fait absolument
rien. En vrai on fait rien pour
l'écologie. Alors on se donne bonne
conscience hein. Il y a moins de
plastique moins d'emballage. Moi, je
vois encore dans les supermarchés des
fruits emballés dans du plastique hein.
Bon ça c'est encore bon. Mais euh quand
je vois les gens qui sont à Sainte et
qui se battent pour pas qu'il y ait les
mégabassines et que les gens disent
"Mais n'importe quoi b de terroriste",
bah non parce que les mégabassines c'est
pas la solution parce que ça veut dire
que tous les gens qui ont plus
d'oseilles vont avoir le contrôle de
l'eau. L'eau c'est la prochaine guerre.
Il y a des gens qui n'auront pas d'eau
et des gens qui en auront trop et des
gens qui diront "Ah c'est mon eau, il
faut payer." Donc tu te dis "Arrêtez de
traiter les les gens qui essaie de de de
sauver la nature et de nous nous
réveiller de terroristes." C'est pas ça
le terrorisme. Terroristes, c'est les
les les fils de vomis du Hamas. Ça c'est
des terroristes. Mais les mecs qui sont
sur la 69, sur les arbres et à
Saint-Soline, c'est pas des terroristes.
Non, c'est des écologistes, des vrais,
des purs, des durs qui essayent de dire
"Oh les gars, on on déconne, il faut
aider la planète là. Donc tu
quel regard tu portes ? Alors ceux qui
se planquent dans les arbres, c'est des
warriors.
Ah pour moi c'est des warriors. Oui, ça
je te confirme.
Ouais. Et le le Qu'est-ce que tu penses
des gens qui balancent des des jus de
soupes sur les les peintures ou qui
déchirent les peintures ?
Ça, je trouve ça nul. Alors,
franchement, ça n'a pour moi, ça n'a
aucun intérêt.
Pourquoi ?
Bah oui. Alors, il y a on va faire un
buzz en disant il va tout le monde va en
parler, ils ont jeté de la peinture.
Alors, généralement
la soupe,
la soupe, ça s'efface et cetera. Bon,
OK. C'est même pas le fait de jeter de
la soupe. Mais pourquoi faire ? C'est
pas ça. Monte dans les arbres avec les
gens de la 69. Je trouve que il y a un
vrai combat. Après oui, si ça peut faire
parler de l'écologie mais ça n'en fait
pas parler en bien. Tout le monde dit
que c'est stupide et les œuvres d'art,
elles ont rien fait. Enfin, tu vois ça
pour moi, ça n'a aucun intérêt. À ce
moment-là, va jeter de la soupe sur
Attention, pas d'incitation à la soupe.
Non, mais sur je sais pas moi, sur des
tracteurs qui vont creuser des gros
trous pour faire des grosses
mégabassines. Mais je veux dire non.
jeter de la soupe et de la peinture sur
des œuvres d'art.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses des gens qui
font des greffes de la fin pour des
causes ?
Ah moi je moi j'admire les gens qui sont
capable comme les warriors qui montent
dans les arbres, qui sont suspendus, qui
prennent des lacrimeaux, qui prennent de
tout, qui font la greffe de la fin. Moi,
j'admire ces gens qui ont vraiment des
combats. Euh moi, souvent, on me dit "Tu
ouvre ta gueule et cetera." Bah déjà mon
petit niveau, j'essaie de d'ouvrir un
petit peu ma gueule et mais moi je ne
pourrais pas monter en haut d'un arbre à
me prendre des fumigèes. Moi j'admire
ces gens
des lacrimu.
Des des Oui, des lacrimu, des tout ce
que tu veux, des Bref, je trouve que ces
gens sont exceptionnels et formidables.
Je trouve qu'il faut vraiment tellement
de conviction, tellement de courage pour
aller jusqu'au bout de ton truc. Alors
là, moi j'ai dit bravo les gars et après
je pense que notre planète va vraiment
très mal et que on est de plus en plus à
essayer de dire il faut manger moins de
viande mais tu as l'impression dès que
tu dis ça euh que tu empêches les gens
de vivre. Mais on vous a pas dit
d'arrêter complètement. On vous a dit de
ne serait-ce que ralentir un petit peu,
de consommer différemment, de consommer
local, d'essayer de manger autrement, de
manger mieux. Alors, par exemple,
moi j'ai un fils qui fait et une fille
qui font beaucoup de tout to go. Tu
connais cette application ? C'est
extraordinaire. Tu as une appli et tu as
tous les commerçants. C'est pas c'est je
trouve ça exceptionnel. Tu as tous les
commerçants qui au lieu de jeter parce
que c'est plus bon, parce que c'est
périmé, parce que la date est passée,
parce que la tomate elle a une gueule un
peu comme ça, les foutres sur l'appli,
tu payes un prix dérisoire et tu as un
gros panier avec plein de trucs à
manger. Ce genre d'initiative, je trouve
ça génial. Voilà,
je trouve qu'on va pas assez loin en
écologie et dès que tu dis qu'il faut
manger moins de viande, tu sais, tu
prends des entrecôtes, on te met des
tweets avec des des barbecue géants. Et
là, hein, alors
je sais plus quoi dire, moi, les gars.
Pensez à vos enfants, à vos petits
enfants, continuez à manger des grosses
entrecôtes. Qu'est-ce que tu veux que je
te dise ? à un moment donné, je je
tu essayes de de
chacun met sa petite pierre, tu sais,
c'est colibri,
c'est le travail du colibri. Je voudrais
que tu me parles de ta perception de la
gestion de la crise Covid.
Mon dieu, la crise Covid, ce
confinement, moi ça m'a pas J'ai appris
à faire des trucs hein en cuisine.
J'étais avec mes gosses et tout, c'était
super. J'ai passé un bon confinement. la
gestion de la crise. Euh
bah là aussi, il y a eu un vocabulaire
qui était trop "Nous sommes en guerre."
Non, on n'est pas en guerre. Moi,
j'aurais aimé plus de sincérité. Les
gars, c'est la merde. On sait pas du
tout ce que c'est. Euh
comment tu fais pour gérer la panique ?
Ah bah, c'est très compliqué. Tu les
gens, moi je me rappelle, les gens
avaient très très peur. Moi, j'étais
tellement dans le Mais qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce virus ? Mais pourquoi ?
Moi, je panique pas facilement. Je suis
plutôt dans la réflexion dans "OK, on va
se protéger, c'est normal, on va
protéger les autres, c'est normal. Oui,
on va Mais après,
d'un seul coup, c'est devenu wou ! Ça
c'est ça a été terrible cette et c'est
là où on a vu que bah les soignants,
heureusement qu'ils étaient là, on a vu
plein de professions qu'on a,
les ébours, les infirmières,
les caissières, les livreurs tous ces
gens.
Mais après le Covid, que s'est-il passé
? Est-ce que ces gens ont eu des primes
? On été Non,
certains.
Oui, enfin
certaines
très petites primes hein.
Chez Systemu, ils ont eu quelques primes
d'après ce le directeur général.
Peut-être. Je n'ai pas je n'ai pas mes
entrées chez Système U.
Mais eux, on les a reçu ici.
Ah, c'est très bien. Merci Système U.
Alors euh,
j'ai le cher Dominique.
Dominique, bravo. Euh mais
de toute façon, là, on est vraiment dans
un dans un instant euh et pourtant,
j'essaie encore de monter sur scène et
de faire rire les gens, mais on est
quand même dans un dans un gros bourbier
là. Euh, je parle pas que de la guerre,
je parle aussi de l'écologie. Euh je
parle de la bouffe, le travail, les les
services publics, tout ce
maladie mentale.
Oh tout. Mais quand tu vois les
Bah de toute façon, il y a des services
entiers qui ferment dans les hôpitaux.
Ils ont plus de lit, ils ont plus de
personnel. Donc forcément euh les
services qui trinquent en premier, c'est
les services tu sais là seul coup tu
sais plus, tu as une urgence médicale
pour un enfant, c'est euh what ? Hein ?
Un accouchement
accouché. Alors là, bon bah c'est c'est
préarmé.
euh la santé mentale, c'est pareil,
c'est pendant très longtemps, on a pensé
que les camisoles chimiques suffisaient,
que enfin, tu vois, bon
là, on est vraiment à un point où on se
dit donc une fois que tu as fait le
constat de tout ce qui va mal,
que tu as éventuellement quelques
petites solutions pour gagner un peu
d'argent et faire en sorte que ça
continue de vivre bien et que ça ne se
met pas en place,
À part pleurer, qu'est-ce que tu veux
faire en vrai ? En vrai,
tu fais une chaîne YouTube.
Oui. Tu fais une chaîne YouTube et puis
tu essayes de réveiller les gens. Mais
en vrai, nous on n pas les commandes des
budgets.
Moi, j'aimerais bien que mes impôts
aillent au service public en priorité.
École, la santé, voilà les services. Ce
qui fait de la France un pays
exceptionnel. Et les intérêts de la
dette, on en fait quoi ?
Bah, les intérêts de la dette euh c'est
ce qui va nous plomber la tête, quoi.
Mais euh
moi, je chercherai des solutions euh
taxe de rich.
Tu t'intéresses un peu, on parlera un
peu énergie, tu t'intéresses un peu au
pétrole, au gaz, à l'uranium, pas du
tout.
Non, je sais qu'on est qu'on est dans la
merde parce que l'électricité on la vend
puis on la rachète. Donc ça nous fout
dans la merde, quel que soit le Bref,
euh
est-ce que tu veux me parler encore du
du Covid ? Euh
Ah, le Covid moi c'est
ou sinon on change de sujet hein.
C'est c'est interdit récréation pour
nous.
Pour moi, le Covid ça a été une telle
merde euh pour les les pauvres gens qui
étaient à l'hôpital, les soignants mais
l'enfer pour eux qui n'avaient ni gants
ni masque avec quand même on a eu quand
même CB Ndi qui nous a dit et Olivier
Verrand. Euh, j'ai failli dire Verlan
euh qui disait que ça ne servait à rien.
On a eu tout et son contraire. Le
me est quand même tout bip. Ouais, le
mec est quand même tout bip. C'est
extraordinaire.
Tu te dis bon alors tu sa plus à la fin
il y avait des nouvelles lois euh des
autorisations à sortir tout seul des
trucs autosif enfin c'était n'importe
quoi
le ndodge
tout était j'ai pas compris. Donc moi ce
qui me faisait le plus
Pourquoi tu as pas compris ?
J'ai pas compris les ordres et les
contreordres.
Ah ben c'était très simple.
Mais c'est c'était très simple à
comprendre. Ah bah
il se retrouve face à un virus qui
débarque de Chine d'une ville où on a
aidé à faire un laboratoire P4.
Attends attends c'est pas fini.
Il se retrouve on a des on a des
antivirous on a plus rien. Donc
il panique plus. Bah oui, bah ils disent
que ça sert à rien.
Il voilà enf il se retrouve avec un truc
aéroporté, manué avec un taux de
rémanence sur les surfaces relativement
importants. Il voit les Chinois
désinfecter les rues à coup de canon à
neige
et il y a Macron, Olivier Verrand et
comment s'appelait notre ministre de
l'époque Agnè.
Agnès Busin.
Busin qui essayait d'appeler tous les
jours notre leader. Ils ont paniqué.
Je j'entends mais ceux qui ont morflé
c'est les soignants et qui étaient sans
matériel qui avait quand même je me
rappelle de ces images de gens qui
d'infirmières qui mettaient des sacs
poubell qui essayaient de se fabriquer
des masques avec du tissu qui n'avaient
rien et là tu fais "Ah ouais fonctionne
bien les services publics ils sont bien
bien achalandés."
Tu as pas vu les infecteiologues avec
une série de bagouses comme Mister T ?
Extraordinaire et les ongles longs bien
entendu.
Bague.
Ouais. Bagouse infecteiologue en pleine
épidomé. C'est un magnifique.
Non mais tout si tu veux tout était
tellement C'est là où tu te dis que un
petit grain de sable,
un virus
c'est d'un seul coup tu vois que ah on
n'est pas très à la hauteur en fait. Et
ceux qui trinquent,
ils trinquent bien cher, bien cher. Je
trouve ça terrible. Comment
? Et puis les familles qui pouvaient pas
aller voir leur famille en EPAD, moi
j'ai j'ai quand même un un ami qui a
perdu son père et qui a dû récupérer son
père sur le parking dans le cercueil
fermé qui n'a pas revu son père. Enfin,
je sais que c'est terrible hein de de il
y a il y a pas que j'en connais plein à
qui c'est arrivé. Vous pouvez pas aller
voir les familles les vieux qui étaient
dans leurs épades. Mais moi, je je me
suis dit mais heureusement mon père est
mort 5 mois avant le avant cette
histoire. Je me suis dit mais sinon je
serais de je aurait été terrible. C'est
ça aurait été horrible. J'aurais je
serais devenu dingue.
Perception des gilets jaunes,
bah c'est un soulèvement populaire mais
ils avaient pas de leader et il y avait
pas d'unité donc c'était génial ça. D'un
sur le coup, il y a eu
une une émulation de plein de gens et
cetera, mais ça a été tellement récupéré
de par la droite, de par le machin, ils
avaient pas d'unité. Il y avait pas un
vrai leader
euh avec un vrai un vrai plan quoi.
Les agriculteurs qui manifestent
bah si c'est pas la FNSEA et si c'est
les vrais agriculteurs et pas le patron
de l'actalise. Moi je suis toujours du
côté des gens qui souffrent. Donc euh
moi je pense que les agriculteurs ont
pas été entendus. C'est pas les accords
de monsieur Lactalis qui vont soulager
les petits agriculteurs. Donc c'est
terrible et c'est terrible et c'est eux
aussi c'est les premiers à morfler dans
toutes ces dans tous ces problèmes. Et
puis surtout
on leur interdit de faire des choses et
de cultiver des choses et par contre on
n'interdit pas les choses dans les
autres pays. Donc il voi des trucs à eux
qui sont interdits et puis les autres
c'est tellement n'importe quoi. Tu tu
dis quand tu es agriculteur aujourd'hui,
c'est pareil que les mecs dans les
arbres. Il faut la foi, faut de la
conviction et il faut de la force. Moi,
je suis en admiration devant des gens
qui continuent de se battre pour garder
leur leur exploitation agricole, pour
essayer
Ouais. le leur dignité et surtout pour
se dire "OK, mes parents, mes
grands-parents ont construit ça et je
vais le garder et je vais garder mon
exploitation et je vais me lever le
matin,
je vais la transmettre
et je vais la transmettre et respect
total. Respect total et c'est je pense
qu'ils ont pas été entendus et je pense
qu'il va pas se passer grand-chose là.
Mais bon,
tu m'autorises à te poser une question
internet ?
Bah ouais, vas-y.
En tant qu'ancien alors une euh une
question internet de Arteus.
En tant qu'ancienne animatrice télé,
a-t-elle un avis sur l'évolution des
émissions de télé de divertissement
comme TPMP d'Anouna ?
On me demande souvent mon avis sur TPMP
et Anouna. Euh moi je pense que la télé
c'est euh
c'est un vecteur et puis tu tout le
monde va chercher ce qu'il a envie de
voir. Moi par exemple qui regarde très
peu la télé, qui une énorme
consommatrice de séries de plateformes,
bah là je viens de voir euh de gentlemen
de Guich. Je vous encourage à le voir,
c'est magnifique.
Je te conseille the Unclared War.
Bah écoute, je vais j'irai de ce pas
les
fondation aussi. La télé. Moi tu sais je
suis trop vieille pour la télé.
Quel âge tu as déjà ?
59 ans. C'est fini. Moi la télé.
Pourquoi tu travailles plus à la télé
d'ailleurs ?
Je fais une émission par un énorme
public.
Mais oui, je sais mais on me donne rien
à la télé. Pourquoi
?
J'ai pas de contrat de chaîne. Je suis
free as bird depuis des années hein. Je
n'ai pas de contrat d'exclusivité ou de
machin. Je suis donc
pas une marque de bricolage qui est venu
t'appeler en disant "Vas-y, on paye ta
chaîne YouTube."
Ah au début si j'ai eu un super
partenaire et j'ai c'est grâce à eux que
j'ai ouvert ma chaîne YouTube, c'était
Black etc. Mais après les gars, ils ont
été aussi pareil que tout le monde
ça a été dur et cetera et puis voilà.
Mais si si j'ai eu j'ai eu un partenaire
au début, j'ai eu j'ai fait des
partenariats quand même un peu sympas.
Mais
la télé tuaimes pas parce que tu es trop
heure de gueule.
Je pense que la télé je suis trop
vieille.
Mais pourquoi tu es trop vieille ?
Bah parce que je pense qu'on aime bien
les Est-ce que tu connais beaucoup de
femmes de 60 balai ? Je te parle pas
d'Élise Lucé qui fait de l'enquête, de
l'investigation.
Toute façon Élise Lu n'a pas 60 balai.
Voilà,
elle a 32 ans. D'accord.
Elle aura toujours 32 ans.
Très bien. Bon ben moi, j'ai 32
33. Mais il y a C'est très peu les
femmes déjà en télé, faut qu'elles
soient plus jeunes. Euh
connerie.
Oui, c'est la vérité. En vrai, euh je
pense que je dois aussi les faire chier.
Il vi Chevrillon, c'est un c'est une
pointe de diamant. Oui, bien c'est ça.
Mais non, je pense que oui, peut-être
que je suis trop grande gueule,
peut-être que je dis trop ce que je
pense, peut-être que euh mais c'est pas
pour autant, tu vois. Donc c'est vrai
que ça fait un long moment que j'ai une
émission par an, hein. Euh, c'est tout.
Mais
combien tu prends pour une émission par
an ?
Euh je suis payée, attends que je te
dise pas de conneries, ça me fait
550 € l'émission. Donc j'en fais
ça va me faire
10000 balles
brut
brut presque.
Tu trouves qu'on paye trop de charge en
France ?
Bah, je pense que pour les gens qui ont
envie de faire des sociétés et monter
leur boîtes, on essaie de faire des
exérations au début, mais je pense que
ça serait bien. Moi, par exemple, quand
je fais des tutos YouTube et que
j'embauche des gens pour m'aider, je
préférerais leur donner plus et payer
moins de charge. Euh quand tu vois que
tu payes deux fois ce que tu donnes en
charge, c'est compliqué pour les gens
qui qui travaillent, qui
je trouve que les charges devraient être
complètement différentes, ça devrait
être autre chose. Ou alors tu devrais
choisir où tu mets tes charges. Par
exemple, moi si on me disait "Tu vas
payer 1000 francs." 1000 francs la fille
100 ans.
Tu habites en Suisse toi ?
Ouais, j'habite en Suisse. [__]
j'aimerais bien. Si on me disait "Tu
payes 1000 € de charge ?" Je dirais "Ah
bah c'est super, je donne ces 1000 € à
l'hôpital." J'aimerais bien qu'on puisse
nous avoir accès à la Cour des comptes,
tu sais, qu'on puisse dire
bah oui, mais enfin voter, je dis c'est
pas nous qui votons les budgets, hein.
Tu peux tu peux lire les rapports de la
Cour des comptes.
Je peux enf
Je te conseille ceux de Philippe Seg,
ils sont extraordin
Ouais, je vais les lire puis je vais
faire
euh Non, non, mais j'aimerais bien qu'on
puisse choisir où vont tout cet où va
tout cet argent. J'aimerais bien mais je
pense que on aide pas beaucoup les
jeunes à démarrer dans des trucs, c'est
sûr. Et du coup euh après les patrons
vont te dire "On peut pas augmenter
parce que euh les charges c'est pas
faux." Parce que effectivement si tu
augmentes quelqu'un de 1000 € ou de 600
€ euh ça te coûte trois fois ça. Donc je
j'entends que ça peut il y a pas que des
énormes patrons. Tout le monde n'est pas
Bernard Arnaud hein. Il y a aussi des
petits patrons qui ont trois employés et
qui essayent de de faire marcher leur
boîte. Tu vois, le patronat, c'est pas
que des mecs du CAC 40, hein.
Est-ce que tu penses que les TPE, les
PME et et les petits patrons, les
patrons peuvent faire changer notre pays
? Est-ce que le changement viendra du
milieu de l'entreprise ?
Bah moi, je toutes les révolutions,
c'est un fait, si tu regardes
l'histoire, ont été faites par la
bourgeoisie. Donc la bourgeoisie, ça
peut être le patronat, ça peut être
l'entrepreneuriat.
Euh en tout cas, moi j'aimerais que la
révolution, la le changement se fasse
par la jeunesse. Merde ! Euh mais euh
historiquement, c'est plutôt les
bourgeois qui ont fait les révolutions,
mais la petite bourgeoisie, je sais pas,
peut-être que
tu te rappelles de la commune, ça s'est
mal terminé, hein ?
Oui, ça s'est mal terminé. C'est terminé
dans le sang.
Tu as envie de parler de quelque chose
en particulier tout de suite où je peux
enchaîner des petites questions ? Oh, tu
peux enchaîner, je t'en prie. Quelle
heure est-il ? Ah oui, tout de même.
Alors quoi qu'il a tout de même ?
Ah bah dis donc, il est tard.
Mais tu déconnes ou quoi ? Tu es encore
parti
et et je t'avais dit de pas garder ton
téléphone et en
Ah merde. Bah oui, pardon.
Il y a que Laurent Alexandre qui me fait
ça et ça me fâche beaucoup.
Oh pardon, excusez-moi. Je suis désolée
parce que c'est parce que j'ai un
rendez-vous après et que donc
rendez-vous après, tu comment ça ?
Ben oui, j'ai des choses à faire donc
Mais à quelle heure ?
Bah j'ai dit dans 20 minutes que c'était
fini.
Ouais ben tu peux lui dire dans 1 heure.
Ah non.
Ah comment ça non ? 30 minutes maximum.
Allez, bon,
je vous aime tous mais 30 minutes
maximum.
D'accord. Alors, je vais te lire un
commentaire et tu vas répondre à ce
commentaire là.
Elle a une vision catastrophique de la
de la de petites bourgeoises
sous-informées. Pourquoi avoir invité
quelqu'un d'aussi creux ?
D'ussi quoi ?
Creux.
Creux ? Bah mon chat, je sais pas. C'est
la première fois qu'on me dit que je
suis creux. Normalement, on me dit que
je suis rond. Euh
vas-y, tu peux claquer la porte, il y a
pas de problème.
Petite bourgeoise, [__] j'aimerais
bien être une petite bourgeoise. Euh,
qu'est-ce que tu veux que je te dise ?
Tu l'emmerdes.
J'ai une vision catastrophique. Bah,
j'essaie de Je pense que je suis pas
sous-informée maintenant. Tu sais,
chacun peut penser
"Tu passes combien de temps à t'informer
par jour ?"
Ah, je peux passer une bonne heure et
demi quoi. Le matin, je me lève tôt et
je passe 1 heure et demi à regarder les
articles à lire.
C'est une gym où tu te laisses porter ?
Non, c'est une gym. C'est une gym. C'est
une vraie gym. Je vais chercher, je lis,
je regarde.
Et quand tu prends une information qui
te met un percute au foie, un crochet au
foie,
tu la digères tout de suite, tu la
digères en dormant, tu fais une
insomnie, tu commences comment tu gères
ça Je mets du mal à la digérer. J'ai du
mal, j'ai beaucoup de mal mais bon, j'en
parle avec mon mec, avec mes potes, on
discute, on essaie de on essaie de
Combien ça coûte au M carré une
ronoration d'un appartement ?
Bah, ça dépend de ce que tu fais mais
genre propre.
Ah, propre, bien ça. Moi, je dirais
entre 800 et 1200 € le mètre carré.
Ah oui.
H
mais tu refais genre
Ah bah la plomberie, l'électricité, la
peinture, plombie isolation.
Bah si tu peux parce que c'est mieux.
Tu suis les cours de l'aluminium, le tu
suis les cours du placoplâtre.
Non
non mais par contre je sais qu'en ce
moment c'est la merde les matières
premières
parce que je discutais avec les les gens
de ta partie, il me disaient voilà on
fait des devis les devis sont de plus en
plus courts. La date de validité du
devis est de plus en plus court parce
que on s'engage sur des chantiers puis
après nous on doit subir l'inflation.
Bah bien sûr, mais toutes les matières
premières, que ce soit le placau, le
bois, les IPN, le fer, ben tout
a grimpé en flèche. Il y a le bois, ne
serait-ce que le bois, le bois pour
construire, mais le bois pour se
chauffer aussi, c'est très très cher.
Donc c'est malheureusement l'inflation,
elle est pas que elle est partout, elle
est sur tout la nourriture, les
fringues, le les matières premières pour
redécorer, peindre c'est bien sûr, je ne
suis pas les cours de l'aluminium et du
charbon, mais par contre je sais que les
matières premières, c'est compliqué là.
Ça, je te le fais pas dire puis c'est
pas prêt de s'arrêter hein.
Non. Est-ce que tu as ou là là attention
une question technique. Est-ce que tu as
un avis sur l'interdiction progressive
de la construction individuelle dès la
RT 2030 ?
Pas de pas d'avis ?
Non, j'ai pas d'avis parce que je pense
que
je pense que ça va être mis en place et
peut-être même pas mis en place.
Peut-être que c'est juste discuter.
C'est des solutions qu'on lance comme
ça.
Tu sais, à un moment donné, il y avait
ce ce on a discuté de du fait que on
allait prendre les crédits, les
épargnes, les les
il lance des trucs comme ça des fois
pour voir les réactions des gens. Mais
la fin de vie,
c'est plutôt sympa qu'il s'intéresse à
un sujet compliqué comme ça.
C'est compliqué à la fin de vie, hein.
Ah ouais,
mais par contre euh
toi tu pour la fin de vie, tu veux quoi
? Moi, j'espère
je te jette je te jette de la falaise.
Euh
moi écoute, je pense que j'espère partir
en dormant. Je veux pas être malade, je
sais. J'ai j'ai eu une mère malade qui a
eu un cancer, j'ai eu un père malade qui
a eu un cancer. Je les ai suivis
jusqu'au bout. Mon père a habité chez
moi jusqu'au bout. Je sais ce que c'est
la maladie, le vieillir, glisser et
cetera. C'est terrible. Moi, je je veux
pas ça. C'est impossible.
Question internet. Valérie dit pas mal
de gros mots. Est-ce que cela Est-ce que
ça lui a posé des problèmes ? Attends,
non.
Est-ce que cela lui a posé des problèmes
ou lui pose des problèmes dans ses
émissions ?
Dans les émissions, j'essaie de pas dire
trop de gros mots quand même. Je parle
Verl parce que c'est une antique de
de boomer
de boomer d'adolescents de merde des
années 80.
Grandi où ? Tu as grandi où ?
Argenteil.
Euh mais non, je dis des gros mots. Non,
je pense que ça enfin ça m'a pas posé de
Après souvent les gens ils disent que je
suis tu vois comme tout à l'heure, je
suis ou une poissonnière ou creuse tu
sais. Des fois je suis une poissonnière,
des fois je suis une petite bourgeoise,
des fois je suis creuse. J'aime bien les
gens qui ont des avis alors qui me
connaissent pas. C'est super.
C'est beaucoup comme ça. On on t'invente
des vies sur internet ou pas ?
Ah ouais bien sûr.
C'est quoi c'est quoi le truc le plus
dingue qu'on t' inventé ?
Qu' Bah que je suis milliardaire tu
vois. que je gagne énormément d'argent.
Non, pas du tout les gars. Euh que tu
vois. Bon après comme je suis pas la
fille qui cache le plus sa vie, je suis
extrêmement sur les réseaux, j'en vois
bien que je suis quand même tout va bien
quoi. Ça va, c'est tranquille.
Tu aurais envie qu'on fasse quel type
d'interview et avec qui ?
Toi ?
Bah ici,
bah le président tiens cette bonne
blague. J'aimerais bien voir face à toi
ce qu'il pourrait dire. Tu vois le
président ou même Atal.
avec des
journées journé
le corn.
Non mais Macron, ça serait intéressant
tu vois. Je trouve que
j'aimerais qu'il ait des vraies
questions parce que souvent quand il est
interviewé, on lui donne les questions
avant ou c'est lui qui les donne et puis
on va on le contredit pas trop, on essae
pas trop de Tu vois. Euh
toi, tu me verrais bien lui mettre une
grosse patate en direct.
Non, mais lui poser des vraies questions
en tout cas. lui mettre.
Tu voudrais que je le fasse comment ?
Façons anconda. C'està-dire je le mets
un peu en en confiance, je mets mes
anneaux autour du siège, je serre d'un
coup progressivement ou ou je je le
laisse s'enterrer tout seul ?
Moi, je suis plus je suis pour
l'enterrage avec sortage de rame.
Je trouve que c'est plus c'est plus
malaisant et donc ça peut être
intéressant.
Et tu veux tu souhaiterais que je prenne
mon temps ?
Oui.
Que ça dure ? Bah, qu'en tout cas tout
soit tous les domaines et toutes les
questions que personne ne lui pose
jamais ou en tout cas ne va jamais
jusqu'au bout, que tout soit vraiment
mis au bout.
Tu trouves que les journalistes sont
vraiment euh euh il ils passent de la
brillantine à chaque fois ?
Bah, je pense qu'ils ont ils vont pas
jusqu'au bout des questions. Je pense
qu'ils ont
à ton avis, ils ont peur, ils
connaissent pas, ils ont pas le
background, on leur a demandé de pas
faire.
Je sais pas si on leur a demandé de pas
faire déclencher des guerres. Je pense
que ils ont pas envie d'aller trop loin.
C'est le président de la République.
Je pense que
je pense qu'il faudrait que ce soit des
gens qui posent des questions,
une assemblée de gens et pas forcément
sélectionné
des gens qui on envie de poser des
questions et qu'on leur pose des
questions. Je pense que c'est après
c'est le président de la République donc
je pense que tout le monde y va
tranquille tu vois parce queon sait pas
trop.
Tu verrais qui d'autre sinon à ta place.
À part Macron ou Atal écoute,
[Musique]
je te donne des idées.
Gérard de Pardieu, tiens.
Gérard de Parieu ou Vincent Boloré.
Alors Vincent Boloré, j'ai vu quelques
extraits de
Bernard Arnaud de
Bernard Arnaud peut-être en tout cas
qu'ils expliquent des choses, des gens
qui ont des trucs à dire et qu'on à qui
on demande jamais les bonnes choses
quoi. Tu vois
c'est quoi le plus dur dans la
rénovation ? Hm.
C'est l'électricité, c'est les
structurels, c'est quand tu découvres
des des rats derrière,
la plombie, je crois,
parce qu'il faut tout refaire.
Et tu penses que qu'est-ce qu'il y a de
plus dur dans notre France à à rénover ?
la plombie, c'est-à-dire la base,
c'est-à-dire tous les tuyaux qui
alimentent tous les services publics, la
plomberie. C'est-à-dire, je pense que
euh à un moment donné, on avait dans la
campagne de Macron, il disait la
transparence
euh euh machin, les yeux dans les yeux,
le truc
h
n'est pas assez euh on va pas on va on
rénve pas les endroits qu'il faudrait
rénover. Voilà, c'est euh moi je pense
qu'il faudrait mettre à plat, il
faudrait faire des référendums sur
l'éducation. euh l'école, l'hôpital, la
santé euh et que on mette une bonne fois
pour toutes sur la table le fait que
plus de médecin, les déserts médicaux,
la souffrance des gens, euh voilà les
vrais les vrais trucs quoi, les profs
les profs c'est l'éducation. Je lisais
encore Gabriel, je l'entendais dire
l'école c'est notre notre arme. Et oui
bah alors arrête de d'enlever des
postes. Alors l'éducation c'est
l'éducation qui peut sauver les gens.
Question
l'éducation sauvera le monde. Question
internet. Que penses-tu des nouvelles
réformes énergétiques ?
Quelles sont
des PE et cetera ? bah que je pense que
c'est très compliqué à réaliser en vrai,
que ça coûtera très cher, que ça sera
très long et que maintenant c'est pas
une raison pour baisser les bras. Il
faut quand même essayer de trouver des
solutions qui coûtent moins cher. Et je
parle pas que de poil à granule et de
pompe à chaleur. Il y a je parle aussi
d'isolation. Maintenant, toutes les
vraies solutions à un moment donné ou un
autre, elles coûtent de l'argent et le
gouvernement peut pas payer tout. Donc
euh malheureusement les la révolution
énergétique, ça fait des années qu'on en
parle et des années qu'on continue à
construire des trucs. Euh question,
question internet.
Bonsoir madame Dabido.
Bonsoir.
Question de AMX. Que pensez-vous de
l'intelligence artificielle ?
Seriez-vous favorable à ce qu'UIA anime
les prochaines COPES ?
Bah moi, j'ai j'ai un vrai truc de
boomer sur l'intelligence artificielle.
Pour moi, tu sais, c'est Terminator,
quoi. C'est euh Donc,
tu utilises un truc sur ton téléphone
d'intelligence artificielle ou pas du
tout ?
Ah, pas du tout. J'ai même coupé Siri,
hein. Donc pour te dire non, pas du
tout. Moi, j'ai un vrai souci avec
l'intelligence artificielle quand elle
peut prendre la place de quelqu'un
d'autre. Tu vois, on a beaucoup parlé de
l'intelligence artificielle qui prenait
la place des doubleurs, euh qui faisait
des voix, des illustrateurs, des
comédiens, des gens. Moi, à partir du
moment où ça n'aide pas l'être humain et
que ça prend la place de l'être humain,
j'ai un petit euh
j'ai un petit problème de ça me dérange.
Et est-ce qu'une intelligence
artificielle pour gérer nos politiques
ou pour aider nos politiques, ça te ça t
ça non ? Bah écoute, quand tu vois la
qualité des textes sur chat GPT, tu te
dis euh je suis pas sûr. Euh après euh
euh
la science-fiction, le cinéma, la
littérature nous ont prouvé que
l'intelligence artificielle en règle
générale, c'est pas le truc qui fait le
le plus de bien à l'homme, hein. Non,
vraiment Skynet, moi je suis très très
Terminator. Euh non, non, faut
l'intelligence artificielle, elle doit
servir l'homme et pas le remplacer. Moi,
j'ai pas envie que ce soit des gens qui
qui prennent déjà que c'est dur de
trouver un boulot. Si en plus
l'intelligence artificielle vient
prendre le boulot des êtres humain,
c'est pas possible.
Qu'est-ce que tu lis comme livre en ce
moment ?
En ce moment, je ne lis pas en ce
moment. J'écris un livre en ce moment.
Donc, je suis concentrée qui s'appelle
Vieille au pluriel. C'est un roman
graphique que j'ai cré avec ma fille.
Donc, je suis concentrée sur ce que je
raconte sur les vieilles.
Quand est-ce qu'on peut te voir en
spectacle ? Euh bah là, fin mai, je suis
à Gni. Euh après euh
je faut que je programme des dates.
Bon euh est-ce que tu as un conseil pour
les jeunes générations, quelque chose
d'impérissable, une bouteille à la mer
qui restera sur les réseaux et je te
jure la prochaine fois que tu reviens,
si tu me fais le coup de partir au bout
d'une, ça va barder.
Bah pardon hein, je suis désolé les
gars. Euh
en plus tu connais le format, tu sais
que c'est très tu moi je pensais que
c'était 1h30 et en fait
Ouais. Oui. Que c'était en noir et blanc
aussi non ?
Oui, je pensais que c'était en noir et
blanc, tu vois. Non mais n'importe quoi
quand j'ai Bref, un
conseil pour les jeunes générations.
Moi je dis aux jeunes générations euh
votez, inscrivez-vous sur les listes
électorales, votez, prenez votre destin
en main. Euh il y a que comme ça que
vous serez entendu. En tout cas, je
crois beaucoup dans la jeune génération.
Moi, j'adore les jeunes. J'adore les
ados. Ça me fait ça me fascine. Euh
je crois beaucoup dans la prise de
conscience des jeunes sur l'écologie. Je
trouve qu'aujourd'hui ils sont beaucoup
plus
beaucoup plus à la pointe que nous on a
pu être. En tout cas ma génération à
moi. Euh moi c'est ma fille hein qui m'a
fait arrêter la viande. C'est mon fils
qui me fait qui m'a fait changer ma
façon de de consommer et cetera. Donc je
crois beaucoup dans les jeunes et euh
pour moi l'arme suprême de la jeunesse
c'est le vote pour qu'on les entende
pour qu'on les écoute et surtout
la solidarité. Voilà qu' à tout seul on
va pas très loin ensemble on va
peut-être pas très loin mais on y va
ensemble donc voilà.
Valérie d'amido, merci.
Merci 5h view et euh bonne soirée.
[Rires]
[Musique]
M.